انضم الينا من عمان لواء فايز الدويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا بك لواء
فايز يعني رغم الحديث عن زخم ميداني
وبالرغم من عدم الحديث بشكل واضح عن بدء
العمليه المضاده من قبل اوكرانيا الى ان
هناك ارهاصات مشهد عسكري ولكن حتى الان لا
يستطيع احد الطرفين احراز انجازات كبرى
لنقل في الميدان كيف نقرا ذلك
يعني الان لو اخذنا بتصريحات وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني
عندما قال الهجوم الرئيسي لم يبدا
وتحدثنا وتحدث الكثير من خلال التقييم
العسكري ان الهجوم الرئيسي لم يبدا واذا
كان ما جرى خلال الاسابيع الماضيه هو
الهجوم الرئيسي فهذا يعني انه كان هناك
مبالغه في القدرات القتاليه وفي الحشد
العسكري الذي تم الحديث عنه فجاء وزير
الدفاع ليقول لم يبدا الهجوم اذا اخذنا
بهذا التصريح وكما قلنا قبل ان يصرح ان
حجم القوه واتجاهات العمل وطبيعه
الاشتباكات لا يمكن ان تعتمد بانها هجوم
رئيسي هي مرحله تمهيديه هي هجوم اولي هجوم
يسبق الهجوم الرئيسي من اجل انجاح الهجوم
الرئيسي من خلال
ان يقوم بعمليات استطلاع بالقوه احداث
اختراقات كشف نقاط الضعف في المنظومه
الدفاعيه ومن ثم تحقيق انجازات
تعتبر كموقع قدم يمكن اعتمادها
لاستغلال من قبل الهجوم الرئيسي الان
القتال يستمد على يستمر على تقريبا 900 كم
لكن هناك مناطق محدده
تشتعل فيها المعارك سواء في لمان ولكن في
منطقه ازيوم ليمان الهجوم روسي والاحتواء
هو والدفاع هو اوكراني في بقيه المناطق
باخمت زابولوجيا خرسون القوات التي تهاجم
اوكرانيه والقوات المدافعه هي القوات
الروسيه حققت القوات الاوكرانيه استيرادا
الى التقارير السيطره على تسعه بلدات و130
كيلو متر مربع واستطاعت
احداث اختراقات في الخط الدفاعي الاول
وليس الثاني او الثالث ولكن كيف تفهم
تركيز ووضع القوات الاوكرانيه لثقلها في
الجبهه الشرقيه تحديدا
يعني تؤخذ في بعدين البعد الاول انها هذه
هذه المناطق تقود الى نقاط حاسمه ونقاط
مراكز ثقل جغرافيه عقد مواصلات تسمح
بالمناوره في حال النجاح وتطوير الهجوم
باتجاه بحر ازوف وشبه جزيره القرم ولكن
بالمقابل هذه قد تكون الهجوم الاول
التمهيدي في حال نجاحه يطور وفي حال فشله
يجب معالجه الفشل والمعالج ستكون في
مقاطعه خرسون وليس في زبروجيا او دونيسك
طيب ان كان عدم انجازات انجازات كبيره على
الارض هو يرتبط كما ذكرت بان المرحله الان
هي مرحله معارك تمهيديه ما المؤشرات التي
يمكن ان نستند اليها لنقول ان المعركه
والهجوم المضاد قد بدا بزخمه الكامل
الان اذا اخذنا الثلاث مناطق الرئيسيه
المنطقه الاولى منطقه الايمان عليهم ان
يقوموا باحتواء الهجوم الروسي وتثبيته حتى
لا يشكل خرقا قد يقلب المعركه راسا على
عقب الان اذا ما توه تم احتمال الهجوم
نذهب الى الجنوب الى الوسط باتجاه في حال
السيطره على باغموت وهنا الاوكرانيين
يتجنبوا قتال المدن يحاول تنفيذ عمليه
احاطه فكي كماشه اذا ما سيطروا على
هذا هذا الخرق او هذا الجيب يمكن تطويره
من خلال الجهد الرئيسي الان المنطقه
الاخرى منطقه زبروجيا عليهم ان يحققوا
اختراق يصل الى توك ماك اذا وصلوا الى
توكمك هذا في هذه الحاله يمكن تطوير
الهجوم اذا اخفقوا في باك موت ولم يصلوا
تكمت عليهم البحث عن البديل والبديل سيكون
في قرصون وهو المقترب الاخضر والاقصر
نشكرك من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي